Vice news is gone
to make you nostalgic to him it breaks
my heart it breaks my heart Vice news
tonight formally shut down and I just
think it's funny that you've got these
Vice news staffers that are like to the
to the original crew that helped launch
Vice news we changed the game blah blah
I'm like that's me he's like you know
you're talking about me right because
like you guys don't like me but you're I
was thinking of like tweet retweeting
them and being like thank you thank you
thank you for the compliment so for
those that don't know I was the first
person hired advice to start Vice news
there was no Vice news they hired me and
then like six months later they were
like should we create a news division
like a brand for this and then they did
and I was uh so they had news in the
sense that Vice would make documentaries
and then it would just they would say
like it's a news thing
and then eventually they decided to
launch a specific brand called device
news I was the first person and so I
brought new methodologies new
technologies and Reporting Styles they
then hired a bunch of people I left
after about a year and a few months and
then they went woke
real quick it was really creepy over
like like a year after I left the
company just went woke woke woke and it
was so weird because when I was there it
was like sex drugs and rock and roll
Tumblr was still around as soon as they
as soon as they got sex off a Tumblr all
the books stuff get out and got spilled
out into the rest of the internet yeah
like coming when you were there at all
or it was just like absolutely not and
uh I mean there was corporatizing you
could feel that but apparently what
happened was uh a friend of mine who was
a higher up said that they had faced too
many sexual harassment lawsuits and so
the investors came to them and said the
only way out of this is to embrace
feminism
and they said you got it and that was
their defense against being sued for
sexual harassment and stuff
wow so the same advice and I don't fully
understand this Vice is just gone or is
vice still a thing but Vice news vice
vice news tonight is being canceled and
they're laying a bunch of people off so
they'll still have something called
device news but the main show that was
on TV for the past decade is gone
ah so is this the first TV show gone and
as the internet is taking over well no
no it's just get well go broke they burn
themselves the first show they had was
called Vice and uh it was amazing
the first the first show just Vice was
so good man Vice back in the day for
people who know it it was basically four
Dudes it was it was sarush it was Shane
it was uh who was the other guy
uh was it no Gavin Gavin was gone at
this point they had four hosts of their
show I can't remember I can't remember
their names
and then uh the show was basically like
Tre weird travel stuff it was traveling
on the World to Crazy places and
exploring and then I guess what happened
was HBO wanted to cancel it and so they
announced abruptly before HBO can
re-upped it that they were already being
renewed for a new season which forced
HBO's hand but then HBO came back I
don't know this is true this is what I
heard when I worked there HBO came back
and said how dare you and they were like
too bad you're locked in now it's been
announced to the press and everyone's
expecting it and so then HBO was like if
we're going to do it then changes have
to be made and here's the best part I
was told that I couldn't host for them
because I was a white dude
that doesn't seem racist at all oh my
goodness I was like but I'm actually
mixed race and they're like yeah but you
know you're a guy who looks too white
and so they were like you and you can
notice this too when you look at the
advice on HBO staff they bring in like
an Indian guy some women they brought in
a bunch of women and so when I had
joined them I said I want to be an
on-air host and I will bring my brand
and the work that I do and they agreed
and then sure enough
I asked them and they were like two
things one fair point I did not have
hosting experience for documentary so I
was doing like basically what I'm doing
now and they wanted more Pizzazz totally
fair so they had me host some stuff but
then when it came to HBO they said your
white dude have a nice day get lost they
didn't say it like that they're just
like look we've got a mandate they want
you know people of color and women but
they just straight up said it oh yeah
hands down I mean I was told the same
thing by Fusion when I worked there the
ABC News company when they did uh they
had the black and brown forum
and they brought in they had like three
of their senior Talent uh cat staff
talent and then One external guy and
this is like Hillary Clinton and Bernie
Sanders are being questioned by a panel
of journalists and so they just said
nothing to me and
so I go to the president and I was like
is there a reason you guys
had the other main talent and not me
your like senior reporter and and the
guy goes oh he's because it's racist
because you're white she literally told
me that
and then I was like but I'm mixed he's
like yeah but come on man
and I was like I mean hey like the dude
was kind of cool I get it I mean he's
just a businessman that's what that's
just set it all up the uh uh makeup
artist for Tropic Thunder and you're
like do me up and I'm gonna go back in
there
I thought that was so funny I was like
okay
well all right then and when was that
how many years ago was that this is 26
2014 or 15. 2015 because it was like the
presidential election they rang Bernie
Sanders and Hillary Clinton and they're
going to be questioned by people and it
was called the black and brown forum and
then I was like I guess being like Asian
doesn't count like I don't I don't count
as like part of this diverse America and
and keep in mind too because a lot of
people might want to say like Tim your
politics no no this is this is almost a
decade ago and I had no politics like I
had politics but I wasn't doing anything
like this my videos were all like I'm
here on the ground in Fukushima Japan
and there's radiation you were a
journalist that's all I was doing yeah
there was no like me coming in the
office and being like here's what I
think about the wage Gap here's
something about guns it was literally
just like oh I did it we I did a
documentary on police brutality and the
Ferguson riots and that was and that was
what I worked on and then when it came
to this they outright said you look too
white you can't be involved and like
that's the world they wanted to create
so get what go bro good riddance all of
you if only your genetics had perform
slightly differently and you look
slightly more Asian I mean almost like
it's so disgusting you hear people talk
like that but like it sounds sounds like
it would have helped you in this case
anyway though
in this case being a more Asian wouldn't
have helped yeah yeah I think they don't
like Asian people no I mean it probably
would have it probably would have but I
actually lobbied to him I was like isn't
it fair to say that like a mixed-race
person is is representative of a
changing America and should have a voice
and he was just like ah you look white
dude you have to like bring your grandma
with you be like no first real look
like that's so weird Paul and Elizabeth
Warren and be like I'm actually this
well they would let her in no that's the
funny thing they'd be like welcome
please sit down tell us about your
native tribe but that's I think that
that's why I can't stand all the woke
people in the in the in the race Theory
stuff in the ideology is because it's
all it's all lies it's all it's all just
not true Luke Rakowski is a person of
color
he's got blonde hair and blue eyes
what's going on oh he's polish so he's
lavik that's right but Asians over
perform so we don't count
and then I I'm mostly white so I'm just
ridiculous I mean you guys are good at
literally everything no matter what so
that is true that's right we made
gunpowder before you guys uh it's true
and the compasses yep
yeah whatever man good riddance to a bad
problem did you see that they just had
the state estate dinner with the South
Korea and we invited all of our like
South Korean adjacent influencers like
mad at Maddox pidgeoli he went with his
mom Angelina and like Joanna Gaines was
there it made me very uncomfortable but
maybe people liked it I don't know
wait like the White House brought so
like the president of South Korea is
visiting so they have a state dinner and
they invite this is typical yeah like
when they had the Canadian one a couple
years ago Blake Lively and her husband
because he's Canadian got to go and this
time you know they always invite some
celebrity so it was like Joanna Gaines
who does the Waco you know house stuff
and she's she's also I don't remember
what percentage but she's also of Korean
descent and then Angelina Jolie went
with her son who is uh of South South
Korean descent and I think he even lives
there now I'm not totally sure but it
did feel a little bit like
weird I don't know maybe no one else
felt that way slightly right pandering
is the strategy nowadays I mean it's
what you have to do to survive well or
die I guess in this case
yeah I don't know I guess maybe they
wouldn't invite me to something like
that because it would be offensive to
the Korean people because they're the
older generation are very racial
supremacists Joanna Gaines one She's
mixed but is she is she half I don't
know maybe because she passes as Korean
but I think she can also passes white
yeah I feel like this is gonna get
everybody talk about this in a way
that's okay where you can pass this two
different and she brought her white
husband most most like most of my life
white people just assumed I was Mexican
it was like the way but for real like
the way my facial hair grows right and
they'd just be like you know they'd be
like oh you're Mexican they have the
best of all three worlds is what you're
saying okay I guess unless unless you're
surrounded by woke people who just don't
don't want to be dealing with what you
are because in their world if they can't
Define You by race they can't Define you
at all they're going to be horribly
racist well there's a solution you just
have to be trans and then you're at the
top you're the pin that's true if you do
that that's true yeah that is the meta
content move is to be like if I told you
my sexual preference would that put me
at the higher higher portion it's
probably a little I don't know like
right there like maybe it's like you go
to these meetings and they say like hey
you you Phil you you can't come in here
and then he goes what if I told you my
sexual preference oh I'm listening
I'm Paulie ah that puts you uh 50 15.
yeah you uh you win you don't get to
host but you do occasionally get to be a
future yes so it is funny so with a
government Government Contracting that
is a thing like when there's a bid out
there for uh you know purchasing a thing
it's like if they're a female owned
business if they're veteran owned if
they're disabled and if they I believe a
race is another one so there are
companies that literally will pick a CEO
who can stack as many of these things as
possible to be the tiebreaker for
contracts well it's like it's already a
structure it's a good news Tim cast is a
minority-owned company thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time